Good morning everyone, so I am talking today
about cognitive computing, the name of my
talk is Domo Arigato, Mr Roboto, I do not
speak Japanese, I copied that straight from
Wikipedia, I'll talk about cognitive computing,
my slides are
available online, ‘snugug’ is the bit
that's important, that's where I'm on the
internet, Github, Twitter, you can find me
there.
So let's talk about the world of cognitive
computing, shall we.
This is Pepper.
Pepper is a robot, built by Soft Bank a Japanese
company, pepper is designed to be one of the
worlds first human computer interactive Android
type things.
It's using the power of cognitive computing
to make this interaction between humans and
computers a little bit easier something not
like the programming we do everyday.
If we talk about cognitive computing we should
probably define what cognitive computing is.
So cognitive computing is a new field of computing,
the types of problem that cognitive computing
can solve are unlike any problems we have
been able to try and work on before.
It's for working with human complex problems,
so the type of problems that were normally
used to be solving in computer science are
not really human complex problems, being problems
that really require a human to solve, usually
things that can be solved with just maths
or just data analysis, but cognitive computing
aims to be able to solve problems that otherwise
we wouldn't be able to do.
It does this by using machine learning and
artificial intelligence.
So not a single path towards a cynical solution,
but rather, single solution, but rather a
problem is tick solution to problems.
It's a very different way to thinking about
computing than we are normally used to it.
It works with human natural input and output,
so think instead of putting in numbers and
getting numbers back or putting in key word
searches, think rather putting in long form
text, like whole webpages and being able to
answer questions on whole webpages without
converting it into anything, or speaking into
them computing and getting things back, or
having the computer understand audio, video
or images and being able to output audio,
video ipages, other forms of long form text.
This is the type of problem solving and the
type of solutions we can do with cognitive
computing it's why it's the new type of computing
and problem solving, I think it's really cool
and lends itself to new types of applications.
Yah, what does that mean, I bet you have all
used a cognitive application, if not today,
recently.
Who here has used Google Now, or Siri, they
are all cognitive applications, they are called
the personal assistant, it's one of the patterns
that we find at Watson that people use all
the time.
Let's breakdown what that personal assistant
cognitive application is.
It's speech in, speech gets transformed into
text.
That text is then run through usually what
we call a natural language classifier to figure
out what the subject of the
sentence is or the subject of the text is
pool out the individual pieces, then runs
the business logic underneath it to figure
out if you are talking about the weather and
you have your location, what is go and find
the weather application, then runs a Speech-to-Text
to transform that into synthesized speech
and tells you what it is, or if you are doing
a Google search or web search it will go and
find what that is and possibly pull back here
are the results for you, or look in alpha
and pull out the individual pieces, these
are all different types of speech input and
then business logic and output.
So not everything inside of a cognitive application
needs to be cognitive or fit the cognitive
paradigm the application as a whole becomes
cognitive when we provide it, when we use
these types of cognitive input and output
to work with it.
That's what I want - yeah.
So... let's talk about, let's see what some
of these examples are.
Let's play a little bit.
I like pepper dancing, pepper is fun.
So, the first application that we're going
to talk about is this little thing that I
built, a little tiny Chrome extension, using
Watson's text analysis tool.
What it does, it's a Chrome extension for
Github, whereas you are typing it analyses
the speech that you, the actual long form
text you are writing in the comment box if
it finds the text is negative, if the content
of your text is negative, it switches the
comment submit button from green to red, if
it becomes angry it disables the comment button,
right!
That's pretty fun!
.
So it's also about this, one of the reasons
why I'm talking to you about this, even though
you might be able, you might not think well
this is probably really super expensive and
probably something that I get access to because
I'm Watson, this is built with a single publicly
available API that you can go and use right
now.
Watson isn't the only group doing this, we
happen to have a whole lot of cognitive APIs
that you can use right now by searching the
Watson developer cloud, this is one called
tone analyser, what winds up happening here,
as you type on key up, the Chrome extension
sends all of your text off to a little tiny
server I made, that runs through tone analyser,
comes back and tone analyser splits your text
into one of three different tones, happy,
negative or angry.
If negative is one or above, I tell you that
you probably shouldn't send that and if angry
is one or above I disable it.
Usually you are angry and negative, but you
can be negative without being angry, that's
why it's kind of that three layer thing.
So this is the first type of cognitive application
you can build.
The second one gets a little bit more complex.
So, this is something I wrote called 'Babel
Fish', those of you that don't know, it's
the weirdest thing in the universe, you put
it in your ear and it translates all speech
into other speech, it's from hitchhikers guide
to the galaxy, Watson as three, Speech-to-Text,
language translation API and text to speech
API, when it's combined you can create a Babel
fish, I will use media to get text input,
it will run through the Speech-to-Text algorithm,
it is then going to translate that text using
text or language translation, then going to
spit it out in that native language.
Unfortunate German isn't supported, but French
is.
What I'm going to do is say English and go
to go to French, I'm going to do it not on
my speaker
notes...
hello JSConf.
Live demos are always fun!
close...!
.
I guess JSConf isn't something that Speech-to-Text
understands, so let's try something else.
'The breakfast this morning was fantastic'...
that's a little bit better I think.
What do the APIs look like under the hood,
is the way that - what you get back from Speech-to-Text
is you get a confidence meter.
This is where cognitive applications sort
of differ from normal APIs that you may wind
up working with.
Speech-to-Text is a little bit iffy it's working
of probability, not confidence, you get the
translated text but you also get a confidence
meter from 0 - 1, 0 to 100% basically.
That is going to tell you how confident it
is in your results.
The first one not so confident, this is pretty
confident, this is more or less spot on.
Then language translation does a one-to-one
translation.
Translation happened between different domains,
you could have - right now there is a news
domain and a medical and a travel domain,
but one of the great things about this is
because cognitive computing is based off of
artificial intelligence and machine learning,
you can learn, you can train it, you can have
it understand your specific domain, if you
wanted to create, let's say a food application,
you could train these APIs, you can train
cognitive systems to understand the domain
of food.
So you don't have to know, necessarily, what
a croissant is in English or French, you don't
have to know what the words are, but you are
able to translate them by training the applications
with APIs I'm using a standard news domain.
Text to speech synth sizes text in one of
a variety of different languages, that just
takes what ever text and goes straight off,
so it's cognitive input, human natural input,
with language translation which is trainable
to understand the different domains you are
working in, then text to speech, a human understandable
output, it makes a new way of working and
interacting with your user, there are only
really three APIs being used here.
The final bit that we have is a little bit
more fun, it's cognitive computing.
So, the first example that we showed is something
that you can build today with a single API,
it's a simple example of what cognitive computing
can be, one API, one natural language text
input, goes off to server, comes back, you
do stuff.
The second one a little bit more complex,
three APIs being used, one turns speech into
text, then it does stuff in the back ground
and gives you speech out.
Be able to hold full conversations with other
people that you otherwise couldn't.
That's also available as three public APIs,
this a little bit future state, it's available
now, just not as APIs, Watson is built on
what we call Watson Discovery Advisor, it's
a system for understanding connections and
being able to find connections between things
you wouldn't otherwise be able to see, in
this case food.
So what we have done here, we have ingested
all of the recipes that bon appetite magazine
has written.
We have ingested all of thinkers, like artificial
intelligence, machine learning and deep learning,
kind of do its thing on them, what you get
out of this, you get food pairings or recipes
you wouldn't otherwise know or be able to
see.
So one example of this, when we talk about
food and we talk about cooking, normally the
food and the recipes that we have, those ingredients
go together , I guess the
police don't like me talking about food!
So food and recipes they generally
go together and the ingredients in recipes
generally go together because they grow together.
They come from the same region of the world
but things like apples and olives don't grow
in the same place but it turns out that when
you look at the types of recipes they are
used in and their chemical compounds and how
other things relate to those 2 ingredients,
apples and olives turn out to pair really
well together, even though it's something
you would never think to pair together because
they don't grow together.
What cognitive computing and what Chef Watson
is able to do is able to find these underlying
connections.
It also have applications in other things,
think law enforcement, we have this demo where
we ingested all of Wikipedia, and you ask
it questions about Wikipedia like what are
the planets in the solar system it's able
to actual what all the planets are with all
the evidence and all the confidence.
You can actually trace back all the evidence
and all the different pieces that connect
together this is how cognitive computing is
a bit different than normal key word search
you can actually see the full evidence tree
of how got somewhere.
Let's build a recipe.
Chef Watson, starts with ingredients.
Someone yell out an ingredient.
Bacon!
Bacon.
It starts to think, we know it has bacon,
it makes some suggestions for us of other
types of ingredients that are known to pair
well with bacon, smoked turkey, some navy
beans.
Soy sauce.
Dark soy sauce, dark soy sauce.
Undefined dumplings.
Yes!   I
think chef has decided to pair Bacon with
more Bacon.
anyway, so cognitive
computing and specifically chef Watson it
goes beyond just ingredients we can talk about
dishes and styles as well.
So let's choose a dish.
Let us do a bacon and soy sauce bloody Mary.
How about a Caesar salad?
Get rid of the bloody Mary.
Maybe it won't do a dish or a style, back
to school.
there we go, so back to school
bacon dumplings.
if we load this up, we wind up
seeing is we wind up getting a brand new recipe
that has never existed before.
So chef Watson didn't go do a search on the
internet to find back to school bacon dumplings,
what it's done it's used the that training
of all the recipes and used the training of
all the different ingredients and the chemical
compounds of all the ingredients to build
a new recipe for you a new human output recipe
for you based on other thing that, but this
has never existed before.
This is kind of, to me the power of cognitive
computing it's being able to not replace humans,
but empower humans to find connections and
be able to interact with computers in ways
that they would never have been able to interact
with before.
In ways you wouldn't have been able to see
or use before.
The best part about this for me anyway, I
am a little bit biased because I work for
Watson but all of these APIs that we have
are for free, Chef Watson you can go play
with right now, and we're not the only company
doing it.
Which is awesome.
Artificial intelligence, deep learning the
foundation of cognitive computing has got
too point where it's coming out of research
for the first time ever the APIs the ability
to dive deep into our data beyond what we
think of as deep data, beyond deep understandable
content is something that is available for
everyone to start using and everyone to go
play with now.
Which to me, means a big win for the future
of applications and the future of our work
and I have I would have been better had it
worked the first time, yes.
To me that means it's a big win for us, it
means it's a big win for users, like we said
I am part of the design team I am an engineer,
a UI architect on the design team at Watson.
To me what this provides is away for us to
design the next generation of applications.
Screw your JavaScript frameworks, use whatever
one you want.
To me that's not what matters I appreciate
I am a JavaScript conference I just gave an
entire talk not talking about JavaScript,
but this is what is important.
Our users are important, cognitive computing
and cognitive applications will provide us
with the means of producing the next great
user experience, not react not angular, not
ES6, they are tools to build them but cognitive
computing is what will let us actually create
them thank you.
Ok can I have the slides back again?
Those are the links, the link to slide deck,
links to all of the source code for the first
2 applications are available online, I am
snugug that's my website, that's Twitter,
that's the slide deck again.
All the links to everything are available
online including all the source code for all
the applications.
Thank you.